So we talked a couple of weeks ago about the
bad idea that is Michael Bloomberg running
for president.
Michael Bloomberg is a billionaire, longtime
Republican turned Democrat.
He owns the Bloomberg TV channel, the Bloomberg
news organization, and he is way, way richer
than Trump.
We don't know exactly how Trump, Richard is,
we, we assume he's exaggerating, but if Trump
is a billionaire, Bloomberg is like a turbo
billionaire with a net worth reportedly of
more than 54 billion us dollars.
We told you a couple of weeks ago, Bloomberg
was thinking about running for president.
He now is running for president as a Democrat
in the democratic primary.
Now, according to the latest morning consult
poll, Bloomberg is already pulling 2% and
an average of recent polls.
Bloomberg is already pulling ahead of Tom
Stier, Amy Klobuchar, Cory Booker, who Leon
Castro and has tied Tulsi Gabard after just
a few days in the race.
That being said, Bloomberg obviously can't
win the primary.
He's just, he's not going to win the primary.
There's no chance.
So what's going on here?
I believe that Michael Bloomberg is basically
trying to prevent Elizabeth Warren or Bernie
Sanders from becoming the democratic nominees
whose policies would directly affect Michael
Bloomberg potentially to the tune of billions
of dollars.
I'll explain.
Bloomberg has said, defeating Donald Trump
is the most important thing, that that's the
priority.
That's what made him consider running.
He believes Trump must be removed.
And Tom Stire, another billionaire who's running
has said that exact same thing.
Now, Stier has a fraction of the money.
Bloomberg has styled reportedly worth around
a billion and a half.
Again, as I said before, Bloomberg worth about
$54 billion.
And I said about Tom Stiers, uh, candidacy
last week after the democratic debate.
If you really want to defeat Trump, don't
run yourself.
You have no shot.
Put the $50 million or however much Tom Stier
says he's willing to spend on his campaign,
put that money into defeating Trump by helping
somebody else put the money into voter registration
and into fighting voter suppression.
Put it into a huge TV campaign to, um, uh,
antagonize Trump and support the eventual
democratic nominee.
If Tom Stire is willing to spend 50 million
to defeat, Trump is the point.
There are far better and more effective ways
to do it than by running himself.
Fine.
Bloomberg has nearly 50 times the money of
Tom Stier.
If Bloomberg wants hurt Trump by Fox news
and stop the pro Trump propaganda, I've mentioned
this before, I'm not literally saying buying
Fox news, I don't think it's for sale, but
the, the point is there are ways that Bloomberg
can take whatever amount of money he's willing
to spend on his campaign.
Maybe it's a billion of his own money.
Who knows?
Spend it in other ways that will actually
help get rid of Donald Trump because Bloomberg's
not going to win.
And that's where we get to the Bernie Warren
element of this.
If you go to Elizabeth Warren's wealth tax
calculator, and you put in Michael Bloomberg's
net worth, Michael Bloomberg would pay three
point $1 billion under Elizabeth Warren's
wealth tax.
So forget about the 50 million that Tom Stire
is spending.
Even if Michael Bloomberg spent $1 billion,
it could prevent Warren from winning and save
him an additional $2 billion in theory anyway.
Now of course let's be realistic.
The wealth tax is not hugely likely to be
made law, even if Elizabeth Warren is president.
I know that this is sort of taboo to talk
about on on some slices a amongst some circles
on the left, but a lot of the policies that
Bernie and Warren say they want will never
be made law.
This is just a reality.
This is the way that it works.
You sort of say what it is, what it is that
you would like to do, and then you end up
having to negotiate on almost all of those
issues merely to a fraction of that.
So it's very likely that Warren's wealth tax
would not be made the law anyway, but there
is no question that the policy ideas of Warren
and Bernie are a threat to Michael Bloomberg's
personal finances.
And increasingly it seems that Bloomberg's
goal is run to prevent Warren or Bernie from
winning the primary and likely to keep Joe
Biden in the lead.
Now this is logical behavior in a sense.
If you're Michael Bloomberg, from a personal
point of view, it does make sense.
There's a practical reality though that I
think Bloomberg may be ignoring, which is
any support Bloomberg can pull from the democratic
primary electorate is more likely to come
from Joe Biden and other centrist candidates.
Then from Bernie, it's hard to imagine too
many Bernie voters saying, Oh, Michael Bloomberg's
running, I'm going to switch my vote from
Bernie to Bloomberg.
Similarly with Elizabeth Warren, it's hard
to imagine that.
So I think it's a bad plan.
I don't think the numbers actually, uh, support
the idea that Bloomberg can prevent Bernie
or Warren from taking the nomination unless
he's actually going to proactively go out
and spend money on smearing them, which we've
not seen yet, but maybe we'll start.
But I think it could just muddle things enough,
uh, that it still could prevent someone like
Bernie Sanders or Warren from taking a solid
lead in the national democratic primary, which
so far with the exception of Elizabeth Warren
for a few days a month ago, uh, they have
been unable to do.
It's a calculation that Michael Bloomberg
is doing.
I think it's a wrong calculation.
I think it's a calculation that's bad for
the country, but this is what I believe is
going on.
Let me know what you think.
I want to hear from you.
What do you believe underlies this Bloomberg
candidacy because he's not going to win.
Is it trying to keep Warren or Bernie from
being the nominee?
Is it as some people have emailed me merely
a nearly 80 year old Bloomberg who sees this
as the best opportunity to make a bigger name
for himself.
He has a lot of money, but maybe not as well
known of a celebrity rich dude as he would
like to be.
Is it merely that?
Is it something else I want to hear from you?
Let me know either by leaving a comment on
this
YouTube channel video.
If you're watching on the YouTube channel
or by sending me a tweet at the Pacman.
What is Michael Bloomberg?
Really up to deep down here,